tonight on Brian Ross investigates this
guy is a hero meets the heroes the
lawyer who took on DuPont over the
dangerous chemicals used to make Teflon
played by Mark Ruffalo in the new film
dark waters is knowingly poisoning
70,000 local residents for the last 40
years Rob the lots work help to expose
how virtually every American already has
those chemicals in their blood and he's
still on the case I first warned EPA 18
years ago and we are still here we have
more than enough evidence it's time to
move forward and act to protect the
American public plus fears about a new
virus highly contagious and deadly and
its potential to spread far beyond China
17 dead already
hundreds infected around the world
including one man in the u.s. in
Washington State is the u.s. doing
enough to protect its citizens and are
shut jay-z's using his celebrity and his
fortune to take on the state of
Mississippi over the horrendous
conditions in its state prisons nine
prisoners dead so far in the first three
weeks of the year even top prison
officials have admitted that the gangs
are in charge of these prisons but long
before jay-z got involved it was this
reporter who first broke the story of
what is a national disgrace from the law
and crime Network Studios in New York
City's Herald Square this is Brian Ross
in Destin
good evening and welcome and we begin
tonight with fears around the world
about the spread of a highly contagious
and potentially deadly virus that first
showed up in China there are already 17
confirmed deaths in that country and
there are reports of hundreds more
infected around the world including an
American in Washington State who had
just returned from China in HealthWatch
now a deadly virus appears to be
spreading quickly in China is China
races to contain the mysterious illness
that has killed at least 17 people the
virus was first identified at a market
in the city of Wuhan last month which
was selling seafood and live animals
this is ground zero for the illness
sparking global unease the virus has
infected nearly 600 people in at least
six countries including the u.s. a man
in Washington state has the same virus
that has sickened about 300 people in
China 100 experts from the CDC are
descending on JFK Los Angeles and San
Francisco airports this weekend they are
taking the temperatures of passengers
arriving from Wuhan China hoping to
prevent coronavirus the spring festival
travel rush saw a mass migration of
people and that has objectively
increased the risk of epidemics
spreading and the difficulties in taking
effective preventative and control
measures we should always be on high
alert and never take this lightly who
Hans 11 million people are being told
they can't leave a major step into
cities and countries fight against this
virus and now to get a better
understanding about this potential
threat we're joined by dr. William
Schaffner an expert on preventive
medicine and infectious diseases at
Vanderbilt University dr. shafter thank
you for being here tonight let me start
by asking you how serious is this threat
really well it's a threat there's no
doubt Brian but we're learning some
things that are cautiously optimistic
one is it's not as deadly as we
anticipated apparently many people get
sick but fortunately very few in
comparison died not as serious as SARS
and the other is as the information is
coming in perhaps this virus is not
readily transmissible from
person-to-person so that gives us a
better chance to get our arms around it
and contain the outbreak and what is the
source of this virus dr. Schaffner this
is a corona virus it's a variety rista
has come from some animal species still
undetermined it's jumped species to us
this happened with SARS it came from
civet cats and bats MERS the Middle East
respiratory syndrome virus that came
from camels bats were all also involved
we don't know exactly which virus which
source gave us this virus yet but once
it's in us the question is can it go
from person to person and if so readily
we're getting more information but it
seems not to be very highly
transmissible knock wood I would say at
this point doctors after do you think
the u.s. is doing enough to prevent it
from spreading to this country I think
we're doing a lot the airport screening
is a first line of defense no line of
defense is perfect but that's an
entirely good thing to do and we've
deployed many people the information
about this virus is getting out to all
of us let me give you an example how
this is brought down to home right here
in Nashville in my own medical center we
have now added two questions to the
routine that we will ask everyone who
comes to our Medical Center in the
clinic the emergency room admitted to
the hospital who has fever and any
symptoms that relate to the respiratory
tract it's low tech no cost we ask them
have you just returned from China or
have you had contact with someone
returning for China we're doing our own
screening we will identify those
individuals put them in isolation deal
with them with appropriate infection
control precautions we can give them
wonderful care and we can do it safely
that's great dr. William Schaffner thank
you so much for being here tonight we'll
keep in touch with you thank you
up next meet the lawyer who took on the
Giant
DuPont company his efforts now portrayed
in the new film dark waters played by
actor Mark Ruffalo tonight's are going
to meet a lawyer named Rob Balad took on
a giant corporation whose chemicals are
now in the blood of virtually every
American it's a fight that is the
subject of a new book that he has
written and is portrayed by Hollywood in
a new movie names Mark Ruffalo and I'm
honored to play the role of Rob a lot in
the upcoming film dark waters the film
is the account of how a small-town
lawyer Rob Balad took on the huge DuPont
chemical company helping to expose how
potentially dangerous chemicals used to
make Teflon had made their way into the
blood of almost every American
whatever's killing those cows is in the
drinking water Rob not only discovered
that these toxic chemicals were building
up in our blood he also sounded the
alarm sharing what he found with the EPA
and also Rob secured the funding through
a legal settlement with DuPont to
undertake the biggest human health study
of toxic chemicals ever but Lots crusade
against upon got its first national
attention in a report that Rhonda
Schwartz and I filed for the ABC News
program 20/20 according to the federal
government some of the highest blood
levels were found in a nationwide sample
of children even DuPont says it cannot
rule out the Teflon connected products
such as its Stainmaster carpet treatment
give off the chemical although at blood
levels DuPont says are far too small to
be a problem we are confident when we
say that the fact the scientific facts
demonstrate that the material is
perfectly safe to use
uma Chaudhary a vice president of
research is the DuPont executive chosen
to publicly defend
the company's most valuable brand name
she says Teflon is completely safe even
if the key chemical is in everyone's
blood everyone has it
everyone has it's in my blood your blood
possibly we do not believe there are any
adverse health effects good things to
have it in your blood there are lots of
chemicals that are present in our blood
in America it falls to us the ordinary
people to prove that these chemicals are
toxic before the chemical is regulated
by our government that is simply
backwards
it's the companies that make billions of
dollars producing these companies not us
the public may only now be realizing the
scope of this problem but the companies
that manufactured these chemicals have
been aware of the risks for decades but
failed to alert the rest of us I know
because I spent the last 20 years of my
career in litigation with these
companies pulling out of their own
internal files what was already there
and was already known about the risk
because of eve's chemicals and we're now
joined by robbed a lot the lawyer who
Mark Ruffalo calls a hero and the author
of a new book chronicling his efforts
exposure list of a lot thank you so much
for doing here DuPont says of the new
movie that features your efforts that
misrepresents and mischaracterizes
executives and employees and actions
associated with historic DuPont in
decades past saying it's entirely in the
realm of make-believe what do you say
well I think that's one of the main
reasons why I wanted to make sure that
this book was available to the public
and for the movie dark waters for for
people to see the the actual events here
of what really transpired that this
really happened you know this happened
in our country in the United States
during modern times during our lifetimes
where you've got contamination on a
global scale unprecedented you know
contamination of drinking water soil all
over the country all over the planet
and in all virtually every living
creatures blood humans polar bears
and so I wanted to make sure all of the
history of what actually has happened
what we do actually know what the facts
actually are are in the book in exposure
everybody can go look and see for
themselves where the truth actually lies
here and Rob were also joined tonight by
Bucky Bailey whose mother worked at that
DuPont plant in Parkersburg West
Virginia and was born with severe birth
defects Bucky was also portrayed in the
movie dark waters so Bucky thank you for
being here when we first met you for our
report on 20 20 years ago you were just
getting married and concerned that given
the high levels of the chemical in your
blood any children you might have had
would have suffered the same plight
so Bucky bring us up to date well it
took us several years to get to a point
where we wanted to have children just
due to the struggles that I faced in my
life genetics told us that uh my
children would have 50% chance of
contracting the same birth deformities
so it took us quite a few years to get
to a point where we did finally through
prayer and faith we made the choice and
I now have two beautiful children
three-year-old son and a two month old
daughter and they are my life freely
blessed
that's great news a question now from
our control room and executive producer
Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda so Rob you were
able to get an astonishing DuPont
settled with you for six hundred fifty
million dollars
if you had thirty five hundred clients
but what about Bucky Bailey's Bar you
able to get any compensation or
connection any satisfaction there you
know unfortunately the scope of the
study that was done you know we set up
this massive human health study to try
to have independent scientists look at
all of the data including what was in
DuPont internal files including their
own study which showed that two out of
the seven women at the DuPont plant had
children with these defects including
unfortunately Bucky as we all know and
the the panel who put together an
independent panel to look at all that
data try to do a bigger study so that
they could get enough cases and enough
instances to be able to confirm we
were links they were able to link six
different diseases including two types
of cancer but unfortunately there just
weren't enough cases with the birth
defects to confirm that link and I think
we're all hoping that with additional
studies and hopefully with even bigger
studies that possibly national studies
that that will eventually be confirmed
but we'll know one way or the other
finally so Rob below you're still
fighting with DuPont yes we actually
still have cases that are pending we as
you heard we had a settlement in 2017
for about 3500 people we had one of the
six diseases linked to drinking this
chemical in their water that was the
settlement for about 671 million in
twenty twenty seventeen unfortunately
because of so many how many people have
been exposed we've got people who are
being diagnosed with these diseases
almost every day so additional cases
have been filed those cases are now
pending and DuPont is choosing to fight
every one of those cases in court
we've also filed a new case where we are
seeking to try to get independent
scientists to look not just at PFOA but
at this wider group of fifa's chemicals
that we now know are out there in our
water in our blood and to independently
confirm what this larger group of
chemicals will do on a national scale
that's pending right now in federal
court in ohio and bucky bailey let me
ask you you're still in the fight
yourself you're eager to make sure
nobody suffers what you went through
absolutely i'm honored to play my part
in it and staying with robb staying with
mr. Ruffalo and others who are fighting
I've met numerous people who have been
impacted by this and still continue to
be impacted by this and I will do my
very best to shout it from the rooftops
that we cannot move forward like this we
need change and that changes what do you
think regulation we need to have this
chemical stop we need to understand
exactly the impact that it has which we
have that in our hands now and now we
are waiting for calm
were waiting for our government to
enforce it we know what the studies have
shown we know the harmful effects it has
on us we can't continue to go about
thinking that there's no effect and Rob
blatantly asked you in Washington you're
not getting that great of a reception
are you from this current administration
well you know this has been a process
now that's been going on for almost
twenty years through multiple
administrations and you know we're
really hoping that people realize this
is not a political issue I mean it
shouldn't be a partisan issue I mean it
shouldn't be red or blue Democrat a
Republican we're talking about clean
water clean blood in a clean environment
something I would hope all of us support
but moving this through the regulatory
system and it's one of the things I try
to explore more detail in the book
exposure and you see that played out in
and ain't taking long the long process
in the movie dark waters as well this
takes a long time to move through this
regulatory system in the United States
and in the meantime at least we've got
states that are trying to move forward
and fill that gap and protect people in
the meantime you know I'm really hoping
that people see what but what people
like Bucky Bailey and mr. Tennant did
standing up one person you know can can
make a huge change by just standing up
and saying we're not gonna we're not
gonna put up with this and things need
to be different well you both have made
a huge change gradual ation - you robbed
a lot and Bucky Bailey thank you so much
for joining us tonight
and congratulations on the movie and
your new book exposure thank you very
much
glad to be here up next our shout out
music mogul jay-z is now going to bat
for prisoners in Mississippi but that's
only after the groundbreaking work of a
dedicated investigative journalist who
first told the story
the plight of inmates held in inhumane
conditions in the seven Mississippi
prisons got a lot of attention this week
when the rap music mogul jay-z went to
bat for the prisoners helping to bring a
lawsuit against that state's governor
and the head of the state prison system
but our shout-out tonight goes to Jerry
Mitchell the dedicated investigative
reporter in Mississippi who long before
Jay Z came along first exposed those
conditions this video obtained by the
Marshall project shows what officials
call a gang ordered murder on an inmate
seen running from his attackers trying
to get away trapped in a shower cell
stabbed ten times and left for dead it's
become a big issue in Mississippi this
cell phone video surfaced last week
matching the details of an incident that
ended Wednesday night with a guard
hospitalized in part of the prison on
site that investigate TV have uncovered
alarming staff shortages at prisons
across the country there is simply not
enough manpower in place to keep tabs on
the more than three thousand inmates
that are housed there but prison
officials have acknowledged the problem
when you don't have the appropriate
level of staff you know safety is a
concern and joining us now via Skype
from Mississippi is Jerry Mitchell the
investigative reporter who's been
writing about prison conditions in his
state there for years and Jerry it
doesn't seem to be getting even any
better after all those promises of
reform why is that well you know for one
me there the staffing level is like half
what it should be and then money-wise
the Department of Corrections the
Mississippi has basically lost about 185
million dollars and that's money that
went to probably state budget go toward
corporate tax cuts those things so
freezes are hurting and you reported
recently on the number of people who
have been killed in the prison what's
the latest death toll there well they're
going to a dance and Parchman prison the
Mississippi State Penitentiary apartment
just since you know a few days few days
before the new year and
awful it's just terrible and you know
it's kind of become a killing zone there
and I you know there again they don't
have the staff to kind of keep security
and as we've talked about for Brian one
of the big problems is gang control and
gays are playing huge role in this and
why do the prison wardens allow that to
be the case have they just lost control
of these prisons well if you don't have
the staff you don't have control you're
essentially acquiescing and giving your
control to the inmates and then among
inmates of course it's gonna be whose
most powerful and unfortunately that
sometimes then often becomes games so
you began reporting on this years ago
they promised to make reforms they
didn't make reforms and now they're
cutting the budget yeah dollars I mean
they promised they'd appointed pass
reform in Mississippi was held up as
this very example that they were going
to save these billions of dollars by
cutting the number of inmates and then
put that money those billions back into
inmate programs and it just never
happened Brian it never happened and who
do you blame for that well state
lawmakers that mean for starters and
certainly leadership all those things
you know the governor is in charge of
the insurance of prisons and in this
case the governor knows all this is
going on the reports almost every third
day of another death in the prison and
yet they did not change the policies
well what he said was kind of said it
wasn't my fault you know now he was
lieutenant governor when all this went
down the funding part of it but he's
basically saying I'm gonna find someone
really good to take over the prison
system but you know be patient give me
time well in the meantime we've had all
these deaths they continue to happen
that's amazing sure you got a new book
coming out called race
it's time yes and that's about some cold
cases murder cases in Mississippi
do you know ever get cynical about all
those things happening in your state we
just got about 15 seconds here burn case
the Birmingham church found in case the
reopen every prosecution of those cases
which I wrote Anna oh boy
well Jerry Mitchell thank you so much
for being here tonight your workers new
book and all that reporting it deserves
the praises of getting from people
around the country who do care about
social justice as to you thanks again
Jerry thank you Brian
preciate or not well that's our program
for tonight thanks so much for joining
us we'll see you back here next week
you